pas de trêve à l'horizon près d'une
semaine désormais que les forces armées
arméniennes et azerbaïdjanaises
s'affrontent sur le terrain cause du
conflit la région du haut karabagh
majoritairement peuplée d'arméniens et
sujet de discorde entre les deux états
depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années les
appels répétés au cessez-le-feu lancé
par la communauté internationale n'y
font rien le premier ministre de
l'arménie nikol pashinian affirme
détenir des preuves d'une ingérence
turque ankara est accusé d'être impliqué
sur le plan militaire notamment est de
faire venir des combattants depuis la
syrie nous avons des preuves
la russie la france et l'iran déjà
reconnu l'implication de l'armée turque
dans l'offensive de grande ampleur
lancée contre l'artsakh le 27 septembre
ankara a fourni à bas coût des véhicules
militaires des armes ainsi que des
conseillers militaires
nous savons que la turquie a formé et
transporté des milliers de mercenaires
et terroristes depuis les zones occupées
par les turcs dans le nord de la syrie
pour le président de la turquie recep
tayyip erdogan le cessez-le-feu demandé
par le groupe de minsk coprésidé par la
france les états unis et la russie n'est
pas acceptable
emmanuel macron qui évoque également des
renforts de combattants venus de syrie
réclame des explications à son homologue
turc
je peux vous confirmer en propre que 300
combattants ont quitté la fihri pour
rejoindre bakou en passant par gaza et y
est
ces combattants sont connus tracé
identifiés ils viennent de groupes
djihadistes qui opèrent dans la région
dalet je dis que c'est inacceptable et
j'invite l'ensemble des partenaires de
l'otan à regarder simplement en face ce
qu'est un comportement de membres de
l'otan je ne pense pas que ça en relève
est donc là dessus c'est aussi un point
sur lequel nous devons absolument avoir
un dialogue de vérité avec la turquie
une situation inquiétante selon moscou
qui maintient ses appels à la routine a
fourni un terme à tichy compte tenu de
ces événements dramatiques nous
considérons qu'il est contre productif
et irresponsable de faire des
déclarations et des actions belliqueuses
de la part de tierces parties qui
peuvent favoriser une nouvelle
escalade lourde de conséquences pour la
transcaucasie et qui peut avoir des
répercussions imprévisible entre
négociations au point mort entre erevan
et bakou violents combats qui se
poursuivent et signe d'impuissance de la
communauté internationale le conflit
semble parti pour durer en transcaucasie